check this out the first thing i want to
show you is from benny johnson many of
you probably saw this already
but this is this is i don't know it's
epic i guess
the amount of democrats calling in a
c-span during the gop convention saying
that they're switching parties is insane
democrats are leaving joe biden's
radical left party for trump it's nine
minutes long
but there's one thing i want to play
actually i don't think i can plug
something it's working but
at the seven minute mark is a woman who
says she fled socialism
and that she's she's like an older lady
too with an accent and she's like if i
have to lay my life on the line for
to defend this country i will do it and
i'm just like i'm clapping
like yes how does it how is that we have
these these immigrants who escaped
socialism
saying i would die for this country and
we have socialists born in this country
saying like death to this country yeah
man that's messed up
well it doesn't translate to the actual
working class check this out donald
trump posted this to his website
this is a letter signed by six may i
believe six mayors yeah
from what's called the iron range in
minnesota
i'll be completely honest i had not
heard of the iron range until this
happened i hadn't either yeah yeah
i don't i don't think there's a you know
not to be just disrespectful but i don't
think there's
a lot of people who live in the iron
range but but
let me let me read this so you get an
understanding of what this means
and the first thing i want to do is just
want to show you that this is the
wikipedia page
for the iron range and they specifically
note that
it is it's a largely unionized workforce
the rural areas remained democratic
farmer labor party not even the
democratic party it's the democratic
farmer labor party this is union
straight up yep
and the dfl basically is associated with
the democratic party
they say the area remains the greatest
democratic stronghold in minnesota after
the urban centers of minneapolis and st
paul they say in 2016 donald trump's
populist message
enabled him to gain ground in the iron
range winning multiple counties and
reducing the democratic margins of
victory in others
well i want to show you what actual
working class people in this country
believe
because there's something i noticed
about i don't know everything from the
far left
they're young unhinged and typically
well
off and they're screeching about
socialism and i'm like none of these
people
work like where's the 50 year old dude
who's like got a construction hat on who
actually
you know does labor you know farmers
right well remember that um who was that
guy paint
banks who was saying that uh the rioters
and protesters can't
get unemployment they're just working
they're not working at all
they have all the time in the world
approaching jim banks right yeah yeah i
think so there's uh
is he in congress indian i think he's a
rep
anyway this republican from indiana is
saying that he wants to
cancel federal unemployment benefits for
people convicted on reinic writing
charges
think about what that means that means
right now there are there are far left
rioters
romping around screeching about you know
how they hate this country
and they're being subsidized by our
taxpayer dollars that makes you feel
real good
oh man let's read this letter and feel a
little bit okay sorry about that
here's you can see it's from donald
trump.com they say on august 28th fellow
americans
as greater minnesota mayors from
democratic cities and the iron range of
minnesota
we write today to formally endorse the
re-election of president donald j
trump and vice president mike pence like
many in our region
we have voted for democrats over many
decades we have watched as our
constituents jobs left
not only the iron range but our country
by putting tariffs on our products and
supporting bad trade deals politicians
like joe biden
did nothing to help the working class we
lost thousands of jobs
and generations of young people have
left the iron range in order to provide
for their families with good paying jobs
elsewhere
today we don't recognize the democratic
party it has been moved
so far to the left it can no longer
claim to be advocates for the working of
the working class
the hard-working minnesotans that built
their lives and supported their families
here on the range
have been abandoned by radical democrats
we didn't choose to leave the democratic
party
the party left us doesn't that sound
familiar that's getting really
repetitive at this point
it is it's almost it's almost kind of
boring to hear it's like i get it i get
it you're a liberal too i know come over
and vote for trump we've all decided to
do the same thing
i don't consider myself a conservative
and even sitting down with sean parnell
he's like laughing like you are not
right-wing dude oh no yeah like
i agree conservatives can see it they're
like get out of here you hippie
skateboarding
you know whatever and but i
i you know the way i described it
earlier is i mean
they hit the nail on the head it's just
gone so far to the left doesn't
represent working-class people anymore
i don't even know what they represent
you know the funniest part about this to
me
is watching twitter the fake world of
twitter talk about the people who are
like calling into c-span and the people
who say
you know the democratic party has moved
too far left watching people on twitter
say oh these are just trump supporters
these people aren't telling the truth
and i honestly am a little bit
entertained to think about what's going
to happen in november when they find out
that these people are actually telling
the truth
you know maybe we're in the bubble but i
just
i don't know i don't believe it i don't
think so i kind of trust myself because
i try to think that i'm paying attention
i give room for other people's thoughts
but they they
they point it out and we still have more
to read in this letter because they go
through uh how trump helped them and
we'll get to it um
but a lot of these people point out the
tv ratings for the dnc where were higher
i think that has a lot to do with the
fact that republicans
uh follow both news sources so i've
shown this graph
before so this is a justification for
why i think you know the
more people are going to vote for trump
for obvious reasons i mean walk away is
real
yeah we heard it on c-span there's no
like never trump is just like a bunch of
crony establishment people
but there's a graf afton show that that
shows conservatives get about
a third of their news from liberal
sources mainstream sources and
two-thirds from conservative
moderates are inverted two-thirds from
mainstream and one-third from
conservative but liberals
the left they only get their news from
left-wing sources
so that says to me that when it comes to
the dnc ratings
republicans were watching yeah democrats
probably weren't watching the rnc
so it made the numbers bigger and then
when the rnc happened you had some
journalists but i doubt regular you know
like traditional liberals watched or
cared but hey
some people are also pointing out that
it's because trump supporters wanted to
watch online
and i think that's a fair point too
because we were watching the rnc and at
first we were watching on pbs
yeah and all they did was like interject
to rag on trump
commentary was awful yeah and they they
had that lady what's her name yamiche
i think yeah where she she had tweeted
out making fun of uh uh
like like slamming the dude um cawthorne
madison cawthorn who who's in a
wheelchair he's um
uh paraplegic yeah yeah he can't stand
and he managed to do it and she's like
he's making light of the people who
kneel
yeah right so so madison cawthorne
stands for his speech at the rnc
and it's like a huge effort because he's
paralyzed yeah he stood for the pledge
of allegiance
for the pledge of allegiance and then
this woman from pbs
says that he's like doing it as like a
slight against all those who would kneel
and i'm like
he's standing up because like he's
showing that he believes in this guy
like
it's not a slight against you it's she's
just standing up i don't get it it's
like i think it's important
it's inspirational yeah but she's giving
commentary during the rnc and all she
was doing was like making like
like just lying and they had one guy on
who like
they did the very fine people hoax yep
they kicked off strong with that so i
was just like
i turn on c-span yeah it was way better
i think that c-span is an
under-appreciated important part of it
is great
yeah you just play it you're like here
and then people calling in too yeah i
imagine
so cool let's read some more of this
later this is really amazing stuff
because now they get into the praise for
donald trump
they say we didn't choose to leave the
democratic party the party left us
yet four years ago something wonderful
happened donald j
trump was elected president of the
united states and he stood up to china
implemented tax cuts and fought for the
working class
now four years later the iron range is
roaring back to life
and for the first time in a very long
time locals are hopeful because of this
president's policies and willingness to
fight for us
lifelong politicians like joe biden are
out of touch with the working class
out of touch with what the country needs
and out of touch with those
here uh those of us here on the iron
range and in small towns like ours
across the nation
in this election there's a lot at stake
but the biggest risk is our jobs our
economy and our way of life
president trump delivered the best
economy in our nation's history and
president trump will deliver for us
again
he will continue to fight for every
american regardless of party affiliation
and continue to stand up for the working
class today
we right to formally endorse president
donald j trump
and vice president mike pence for four
more years and we got
larry kuff of mayor virginia john champa
mayor of chisholm chuck novak
mayor of elliot chris swanson mayor of
two harbors
robert vlasavv legit i'm sorry i can't
pronounce i'm not trying to be mean but
velai
vlasov livich i hope i got it right i
definitely didn't mayor of evoluth
and andrea zupinich zupanchich
i'm probably i can't pronounce these
names just i mean
yeah i just that's my that's my bad no
disrespect
mayor of babit so these six mayors and
this is like i mentioned according to
wikipedia
the greatest democratic stronghold in
minnesota after the urban centers of
minneapolis and st
paul not even the suburban areas of the
twin cities
i really like this look at this okay it
goes the iron range is known for cornish
pastries stuffed with carrots ground
beef and potatoes pasties were an easy
lunch for people working deep in the
iron mines
slovenian and croatian immigrants
brought the honey nut bread called
potaka to the iron range region that
still served at eastern christmas in
northern minnesota
that is really cool like so those crazy
last names we're seeing are actually
from slovenia
cool croatia that's neat i kind of like
that piece of history from them
and you know what about them and the
democrats they call it the flyover
states yeah that's nonsense this is a
really cool place
particularly disrespectful to people who
don't live in new york and los angeles
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you